Hi., I’m Adriene Hill and Welcome back to
Crash Course Statistics. Today we’re talking
about relationships. No, not why you and your
bestie are platonic soulmates, or why your
cat just doesn’t seem to like you, we’re
talking about data relationships like how
you can use one variable to predict another.
Like if you can predict whether people who
write in all capital letters are more likely
to default on loans. Whether people drive
faster after they watch Fast & Furious movies.
Or whether blink more often when they're lying.
INTRO
We’ll start with the simplest data relationship,
one between two continuous variables, also
called bivariate data. But first, we’re
going to need to visualize our data using
a scatter plot.
The scatter plot has been called “the most
versatile, polymorphic, and generally useful
invention in the history of statistical graphics.”
Impressive....And...as such...they are pretty
much everywhere.
Including on your favorite news site...News
outlets now have data journalists on staff
to visualize and make sense of data.
To make a scatterplot of Old Faithful eruption
duration and latency--which is the time between
eruptions-- we put one variable on the x -axis
and the other on the y-axis. Then each data
point is placed so that it’s in line with
both it’s eruption duration, and it’s
latency.
Now we can see a relationship. There are clusters,
two blob-y looking groups of points, which
supports our guess that there are likely two
kinds of eruptions, one with a longer build
up and longer duration, and one with a shorter
build up and shorter duration.
Just like the histogram and dot plot, a scatter
plot allows us to see the shape and spread
of data--but now in two dimensions! This data
is clustered, but scatter plots are useful
for identifying all kinds of relationships,
both linear and nonlinear.
For now, let’s focus on linear relationships
with a classic example--the relationship between
the the heights of fathers and sons. It makes
sense that a tall father would produce a tall
son, but we can do better than just a hand
wave-y statement.
In 1903, the statistician Karl Pearson published
an influential paper--in his own journal,
Biometrika. One section of the paper describes
the relationship between the heights of dads
and their male children.
In this paper, Pearson fit a line through
the data to describe the relationship, rather
than just relying on his eyes to see a pattern.
The line--called a regression line--is the
line as close as possible to all the points
at the same time.
And note here Pearson used feet and inches
in his paper so we will too.
Lines are a great way to describe a relationship because they have a nice formula, y = mx + b
just like you learned in algebra. The m
--or slope--tells you a lot about your data.
It tells you that an increase in 1 inch of
a father’s height, leads to an increase
of m in the son’s height (about half an
inch in Pearson’s paper).
So on average dads who are 6’1 tall have
sons that are about half an inch taller than
the sons of fathers who are 6 feet tall. That
allowed Pearson to make a prediction about
the height of the son from the height of the
father.
And this is why these lines are so useful;
they allow us to pretty accurately predict
one variable based on the value of another.
The relationship between car weight and gas
efficiency allows us to be pretty sure a SMART
car gets better mileage than a Hummer.
One note of caution: the slope relies heavily
on the units of x and y since it’s a measure
of how many units y increases with each increase
of 1 unit in x. If I decided to measure the
Son’s height in meters, the m...or slope...
will change, even though the relationship
didn’t.
When we see a non-zero slope--also called
a regression coefficient--it’s a sign that
there’s some kind of relationship between
our two variables, but that’s pretty much
all it tells us. We don’t know how strong
that relationship is. For more information,
we need to look at correlation.
Correlation measures the way two variables
move together, both the direction and closeness
of their movement.
You may have read articles claim that there’s
a positive correlation between exercise and
heart health. That just means if you exercise
more, your heart tends to be healthier. A
positive correlation looks something like
this on a scatter plot:
While a negative one, like the correlation
between number of cigarettes smoked each day
and lung health, might look like this. Higher
values of cigarettes smoked tend to have lower
values for lung health:
We now know what correlations look like in
general, but to understand them more deeply,
we’re going to take a closer look.
If two variables have a positive correlation,
they move in the same direction. We can see
this in our scatter plot if we draw two lines
across the graph--one at the mean of each
of our variables--to divide the plot into
four quadrants.
When two values are positively correlated--like
how many miles you run and the number of calories
you burn--most of the points will be in the
upper right and lower left quadrants. In these
quadrants, the values for miles and calories
burned are either both large, or both small.
The more miles you run, the more calories
you burn.
The opposite happens when the correlation
is negative, like the relationship between
vaccination rates and the rates of preventable
illnesses. Instead of moving together, the
variables move in the opposite direction.
So, the points are mostly in the upper left
and lower right quadrants where either vaccination
rate is small and rate of illness is large,
or visa versa. Since vaccination rate and
rate of preventable illness have a negative
correlation, as vaccination rates increase,
rates of preventable illness decrease.
The more closely two variables move together...
the stronger the relationship will be, positive
or negative.
If the points are in all of the quadrants
pretty evenly. You just have a blob or a cloud.
You don’t have a strong relationship.
As I mentioned before, the units of your variables
can affect the regression coefficient, and
can also affect the calculation of our correlation.
To get around that, we use the standard deviations
to scale our correlation so that it is always
between -1 and 1. This is our correlation
coefficient, r.
Interpreting r involves two things: the sign
of the number...that is whether it’s positive
or negative and how big the number is. The
sign will tell you whether your two variables
move together (positive r), or in opposite
directions (negative r).
A correlation of 1 or -1 would be a perfectly
straight line, meaning you can exactly predict
one value from the other. Say we looked at
correlation of the number of hours you’re
asleep vs. awake. If I know one of those values
I can tell you exactly what the other one
is. We all have only 24 hours a day even Beyonce.
As you get closer and closer to a correlation
of 0, the points are more and more spread
out around our regression line, and eventually
at 0, there’s no linear relationship at
all...it’s just dots.
When you look at a scatterplot, remember that
you can’t deduce a correlation just by the
steepness of the regression line. In our earlier
father/son heights example we changed the
units to meters and our line didn’t look
as steep, even though it’s the same data.
Data with steep lines can have low or high
correlations.
We also use the squared correlation coefficient
r^2 .... R^2 is always between 0 and 1, and
tells us--in decimal form--how much of the
variance in one variable is predicted by the
other. In other words, it tells us how well
we can predict one variable if we know the other.
While they won’t usually give R^2 an explicit
mention, you’ll see articles claim things
like “ the ounces of soda a person drinks
is highly predictive of weight”, which means
there’s a large R^2. You can think of R^2
as a measure of how accurate your guesses
would be if you used your linear equation
to predict one variable from another.
If you have an R^2 of 0.7 for the cigarettes
and lung health data that would mean cigarette
usage predicts 70% of the variation in how
healthy our lungs are. You could pretty accurately
predict someone’s lung health if you knew
how many cigarettes they smoked.
An R^2 of 1 means you can perfectly predict
one variable from the other since 100% of
the variation is in one variable. This can
seem pretty obvious when you think about conversion.
Like temperature in Fahrenheit can be predicted
by temperature in Celsius. In this case we’re
not actually measuring the temperature in
Farenheit, but it is perfectly predicted by
Celcius. So in general, the higher the R^2,
the better the fit.
Crash Course World News
Breaking news from city hall today! The mayor
has announced a plan to cut down on the number
of people who drown every year.
Sources close to the Mayor tell us that he’s
seen some very interesting correlations between
drownings and air conditioning usage and drownings
and Nicolas Cage movies. Or as I like to call
it...air cons and Con Airs.
Both are highly correlated with drownings.
Here’s evidence.
If we look at AC sales data over the past
10 years. And even more proof if we look at
Nicolas Cage movies over the same time period.
The Nic Cage data was provided to the city
by Tyler Vigen.
So as of today, our mayor has enacted the
Cool-Cage act which will prohibit sale of
air conditioners and create a Nicolas Cage
task force who will do everything-- to prevent
Nicolas Cage from starring in any movies.
The Mayor assures us that because of the strong
correlations she saw, as well as the strong
will of our city, we will surely have next
to no drownings this coming year.
The Cool Cage act may seem silly, but we’re
constantly flooded with messages--that equate
correlation with causation. And as you’ve
heard before: CORRELATION DOESN’T EQUAL
CAUSATION.
Just because two variables are related doesn’t
mean that one variable causes the other. The
examples the mayor uses are perfect examples of things that can go wrong when interpreting correlations.
When one thing (A) is correlated with another
(B), there’s a few possible reasons
A causes B
B causes A
There’s a third Variable C that causes both
A and B, even though A and B aren’t related
Or there’s no relationship at all. it’s
just a coincidence.
The correlation the Mayor saw between air
conditioning and drownings is probably caused
by a third, unmentioned variable: heat! When
it’s hot people buy more air conditioners
and go for a swim leading to a correlation
even though there’s no direct link between
the two.
And as for Nicholas Cage, he probably shouldn’t
feel too guilty about causing world-wide drownings.
Sometimes two completely unrelated things
are correlated just by random chance, with
no causal link at all.
These correlations get called spurious correlations,
and they can be hard to catch.
But when the correlation is between two VERY
specific things, like Nicholas Cage movies
and all drownings in 3 feet of water when
a dog was present you should be suspicious
that someone tried every weird subset of data
until they found a relationship.
Before we finish with correlation, I just
want to warn you: r and R^2 aren’t everything;
It’s important to look at a scatter plot
of data when you can.
These are the “Datasarus Dozen”... these
very different plots all have the same correlation,
but we can see that the relationships are
completely different.
Correlation is an important piece of the puzzle
when you’re looking for a linear relationship
between two variables. It goes above and beyond
the Y=mX + b and gives us information about
how well that line explains the data.
Understanding the relationships between variables
and events helps us predict what things are
going to happen in the future, and also reflect
on why things occured in the past.
A correlation could help you predict how much
money you’ll make after years of working
your way up as a lemonade salesperson. Or
if watching that next Fast and Furious movie
in the theater...might encourage people to
speed. According to an analysis by a Harvard
Medical School professor Anupam Jena those
two things do look related.
Relationships are important--the human kind
and the data kind.
Correlation allows us to better understand
relationships between data.
And maybe also the data of our relationships.
Maybe you can find correlations between the
amount of time you spend at work or school
and with how much affection your cat shows
you. Mr. Fluffy misses you.
Thanks for watching. I’ll see you next time.